video contains a sponsored segment from
blinkist tell me that this isn't one of
the most beautiful things that you've
ever seen
don't actually tell me i'll be very
upset because i'm very proud of it hello
everyone i'm alana and i got these two
big beautiful statues from the
incredible people at prime one studio
uh this is of course kratos and atreus
this is boulder let me just flip the
camera around i have already made a
video that is an unboxing of the statues
themselves but why on earth would i not
show them off again when given the
opportunity to i think this is also my
first time actually displaying them
posed towards each other they do not
have to go like that they are
technically two separate statues and not
one whole piece um this little god of
war logo in the middle here kind of
links them up together i love it i love
the pose they look incredible and when i
first got them i had these grand plans
of putting them on this bookcase maybe i
would put them on a box
i really didn't know um i didn't realize
how big the bases would be they are huge
like the statue itself is big
but let me grab something for scale
nintendo switch for scale is the new
banana for scale they're really big so i
couldn't figure out how i was going to
display them obviously i've been a
statue collector pretty much my whole
life that's not true but it's been over
a decade now that i've been collecting
stuff like this and all of your standard
go-to's that my other collectors will
know of
were either too small
or out of date for too long even all the
ikea stuff was too small these guys are
too big and then yeah there are some
statues that you can get just found some
dog hair on it that's cool
there is a company that does make
displays that's very popular in the
collectors community but they were like
a year out and i didn't want to wait
that long because i had them sitting on
the floor which is not ideal so i
reached out to a company called pedestal
source actually what i did was reach out
to sideshow collectibles directly i have
a friend who works at sideshow and i was
like do you know anybody who can help me
with these sideshow does sell prime one
statues and obviously they have displays
so i was like i don't know what to do
help me out very big thank you to andy
from sideshow who introduced me to
pedestal source and pedestal source is
the company that made me this big
beautiful
custom display obviously i have not
filled this area up and some of the
books have been chewed by one of my
foster dogs it happens
but i will get there i didn't know
exactly what i wanted i just knew what
my problem was um i knew that i had
statues that were very big i knew that i
wanted it to look cool and i wanted to
make a real display piece out of them
and i knew that i didn't want to waste
too much space i just moved out of what
was actually a 320 square foot studio
apartment i always said 400 it wasn't
even that big so if i can avoid being
cluttered again that would be nice
naturally they did not have any standard
options that would fit this ridiculous
size but pedestal source also largely
makes customs they make display pieces
for shops museums art obviously stuff
like this for people's homes and
naturally i assume have worked with
sideshow and i was like okay here are
the things
here are the dimensions of these statues
what do i do what should i do and
that communication was fantastic before
i talk about more about the process
let's just show you the pedestal and
what it actually does because it's
awesome so obviously we have our statues
they are on this
nice base here and then these two
shelves
are
relatively um
shallow they're not too deep
intentionally uh for bookcases i will
fill them up with books and you know
probably go to all collectibles as well
if you don't know me i work at santa
monica studio who makes god of all i
hope that that makes this make more
sense if you didn't know that the thing
itself is pretty chunky um but
thankfully lines up perfectly with this
door frame here
and with my other desks in this room
but here's the kicker okay
boom baby the top of this thing is
frosted acrylic that is what pedestal
sauce makes most of their pedestals from
on the top because it gives you this
nice
diffused light um this is obviously red
with the saturation the whole way up you
want to lighten that a bit oh my
it is time to talk about blinkist
blinkist is an app that's designed to
help you uncover
powerful ideas basically it gives you
a 10 15 minute insight into a topic that
you might otherwise have found too
difficult to digest or felt like you
didn't have the time to dive into you
can get a bunch of information that you
would otherwise need from a book or from
a million different google searches all
in one place it doesn't waste your time
and i really love that about it my first
go-to when blinkist reached out was to
look up things about video games in the
games industry and see what things i
could read on here that are only 15
minutes that again otherwise i may not
read there was one that i particularly
like that i want to recommend by jane
mcdonald called reality is broken and
it's about why games make us better and
how they can change the world and is
this like really positive look
into the video game industry that if you
ever need some statistics to pull out
the next time families on you about
playing too many video games you got
some facts here for them i promise
blinkist's goal is to essentially widen
your knowledge on a bunch of different
things a lot of the front page has
recommendations on business which is
stuff again that can seem very difficult
to get into that they make very
accessible and very easy to understand
there's a lot of psychology stuff in
here that's really interesting again a
lot of stuff that like you'd otherwise
have to go out of your way to buy a book
for and then read the whole book and
that's a lot of commitment blinkers kind
of gives you the most important tidbits
all in one place on this one app i see
blinkist as like a self-care which is
why i'm a really big fan of it it is you
taking the time and even a small amount
of time to learn something about
yourself about something you're
interested in and right now blinkist has
a special offer for my audience the
first 100 people to sign up to blink is
using my link blinkist.com alana pierce
will get unlimited access for one week
and 25 off if you get the full
membership what if we what if we just
change the whole color let's make it a
nice white there you go match the room a
bit right there a bit too bright bit too
bright let's dim it let's dim it oh
dude it's so cool
so this is obviously just like a rainbow
wheel you can get
a real specific
and then yeah saturation
light and there are also like a couple
of modes that just do fun stuff like a
little flash and rainbow type thing
there that you can toggle on and off
for the most part i feel like i just
leave it at this white but i've been
changing it kind of in the background of
videos to do
different things basically like just
based on the vibe of the videos it's
getting a little bit icy you could just
go white and then maybe lighten it up a
bit
let's do like a there like a cool blue
you know maybe it's maybe it's maybe
it's royal
a nice royal purple basically you got
options i yeah tend to leave it at this
like white that's about there because i
feel like it suits the room but this is
all through this obviously it's plugged
into a power outlet which is just to the
side of it and it is conveniently hiding
some cables that i have running behind
the back of it some facts i can give you
the whole thing is a white laminate made
on particle board it is very heavy but
also very sturdy thankfully it slides
really well on the floor if i need to
move it because there is no way that i
am lifting this thing up by myself
literally ever
the lights are leds and it is very soft
i am unable to see a single light um
this diffuse works so well that yeah if
there is
you know your usual little bulb under
there never been able to see one they
did build in some support rods
underneath the acrylic for me because
the statues are so heavy so to support
the weight of the statue so it's even
more amazing to be that you can't see
any interruption in that like even glow
one thing that they didn't include which
they do often include um which is
because it kind of wasn't necessary
is also an led toe kick so that you
could have leds i could probably even
have them on the shelves or on the
bottom if i wanted to which might have
even made the whole thing look cooler
but i'm happy with just the top for me
because it is of course a one of a kind
it is the only one like this that has
ever been made they do have loads of
just standard pedestals of different
sizes but i needed something
a little bit more specific this is also
their first ever time doing a bookshelf
underneath which was of course my
request i was like okay
this thing has to be huge i recognize
that it has to be really big and it is
takes up a full corner of this room
it's not small and i like i said still
wanted to try to utilize the space um
knowing that i i'm basically still
moving in i moved in november but i'm
still like unpacking stuff and buying
stuff it's a long process and i was like
yeah i don't want it to just be a big
wasted block so they gave me the
bookshelf underneath first time ever and
intentionally the depth of the shelf is
a little bit forward which is so that
there isn't just like a big useless
gap in the back that would just get
dusty
or like hide things so it is like
halfway up sort of in terms of the depth
of the actual pedestal
because that will make more sense for
books ultimately they said that about
seven people in total contributed to
designing this one and then it took
about two days to build which is like
incredibly impressive to me and they
sent me a video which was very very cool
um to give me an update so not only was
this whole process like me being like
this is this possible what are the
options they sent me multiple videos
throughout the process one that was like
okay we can give you this top light if
you like that will give you a more
dramatic look or you can go bottom lit
you could have them spin if you want to
and obviously i didn't want to do that
so they sent me videos of like all the
different stuff that they could do and
then i kind of narrowed it down for what
i wanted and then once they were working
on it they sent me a video of it in
progress
just like genuinely incredible customer
service this was like a very cool
experience to figure out what exactly i
was going to do and i yeah i'm just so
stoked i think this is so awesome and i
wanted to make a full video because
people were like what is that where did
you get it link please but of course it
is one of a kind
they were really explicit with me though
about
like wanting to get more involved in the
market for
collectors
like nerd collectors not like
art collectors they mentioned that the
collectibles market has bought them a
bunch of like really fun customers and
collaborators like sideshow and because
a bunch of them are gamers or like comic
book readers it's just people that they
really like working with which i can
relate to but their price point is high
so it is competitive and reasonable for
what they're actually doing
um is no more expensive than any other
company is making very similar things
the fact is just this kind of thing is
expensive so i think i think that's a
cool opportunity is
if you are a collector and you want to
give them input on what you would
consider to be like very cool
in terms of getting a pedestal like do
you want pull out trays where you could
keep extra pieces for action figures
would you like it to have doors do you
want them all to have glass tops because
i could have had a glass case on the top
as well but decided against it because
i don't want the shine to ruin the
display but they basically were like
yeah we'd love to find a nice marriage
between what the nerdy collectors want
and the price point so i would say
if you legitimately would like to
be involved in that if you leave a
comment below of the kind of thing that
you would be looking for in terms of
like a display like this and how much
you'd be willing to pay for it or what a
price point would be for you um i can
almost guarantee that they will they
will read the comments on this video and
that's a cool thing to
like be able to try to help out with
because there are some companies that
are doing stuff a lot of people who are
collectors use ikea but that can also be
really limiting and
this is so much cooler it's so cool but
yeah that's the bulk of this video i
just wanted to show it off answer some
of the questions people have been asking
me about it because of course it's been
in the background of a bunch of my
videos now and will continue to be i was
originally going to have it on a
different side of the room and i'm
intentionally being coy with how i show
the office because
there's like a game dev corner of this
room which i try to hide from the
internet and then i swap them around um
so now it is always in the background of
videos which i love it's so cool
honestly
you know
the statues themselves are obviously
top tier i do already have a video about
them i love the posing
but
as soon as i have this bookshelf
together i swear it's gonna look
awesome so yeah a huge thank you to
pedestal sauce for their help this was a
very fun experience like working on the
design with them being very
collaborative and back and forth and
having them help me figure out what i
wanted and then seeing it arrive and
seeing what it actually looked like in
person was like it was just really cool
very very very exciting stuff so very
big thank you to them i'll leave a link
in the description to where you can
check them out please leave a comment if
you're a collector about the kind of
thing that you would like to see because
they are really interested in getting
more collectors involved and really like
working with them and otherwise yeah i
hope that answers all the questions
about it sorry i don't have a link it is
a one of a kind i love it so much